I'm P Morgan on Sor tonight Shany Luke
was the young t two artist whose
kidnapping became a powerful symbol of
hamas's murderous brutality her mother
thinks she could still be alive she'll
tell me why and I'll talk to the Israeli
Ambassador about the Hamas
hostages Pro Palestine protests so
division in major cities are they
calling for peace or apologizing for
Terror I'll debate that with one of the
more popular Palestinian YouTubers Pro
Palestinian YouTubers plus professional
fighter Dylan danis is beaten in a
boxing bout by another YouTuber Logan
Paul can he recover his credibility
joins me live in the
[Music]
studio live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensor
good evening from London welcome to PG
sensor sometimes it takes a tragedy to
expose people's true colors in their
lurid detail the conflict in Israel has
certainly done that the men women and
children butchered by Hamas had barely
been zipped into body bags before many
people started using a terrorist attack
as Grist whatever politics they' already
had the blood Hamas spilled are barely
dried into the Derp before the streets
of Western cities filled with flag
waving supporters of Palestine demanding
the straight and deescalation some even
showing Hamas Flags protest this weekend
in London other major cities want a good
look to be clear they've got every right
to Peaceful Assembly not to wear badges
celebrating the Hamas paragliding
terrorists not to threaten and abuse
people disagree with them like
[Music]
this
well a man at the center of that scrum
as he was threatened with a knife
Reports say protesters chanted from The
River To The Sea Palestine must be free
which is nothing if not an incitement to
violence it's divisive hateful it
undermines the argument that this was a
March for peace and Muslim solidarity if
that's what it's about it's worth asking
where were all these people when China's
genocide against the weu Muslims was
being exposed it's worth asking what is
it about Israel specifically that brings
them to the streets Israel seems to be
the only country in the world that's
expected to respond magnanimously to a
massacre of 1,300 of its people are
child killing extremists who let us not
forget want to wipe it from the face of
the Earth what if this would happen in
Britain or in the US proportionately
this attack was equivalent to 30,000
Americans being slaughtered on American
soil would we really be in any mood for
restraint if this had happened here in
Britain at the same time we shouldn't be
celebrating the response we can't
pretend that many innocent Palestinians
some of them bitterly opposed to Hamas
might be killed in the retaliation and
the attempt to get back the hostages
Israel has every right to respond let me
make that crystal clear and I get but
it's in no mood for lectures after the
barbarism of last weekend but the
punishment cannot be just as wicked as
the crime civilians in Gaza they need
water they need food they need Humanity
Israel had the high moral ground and it
has it today but needs to stay there
starving civilians and fueling the next
generation of terrorists will not be the
way to do it and as Israel prepares a
massive ground operation in Gaza it must
remember the Israelis taken their as
hostages by Hamas and get them back if
they can innocent people like shaie Luke
whose brutal kidnapping from music
festival became a powerful symbol of the
brutality inflicted on her country we
don't yet know her fate at least
199 Israelis are still being held by
Hamas their families is paralyzed by
fear forget the ugly tribalism all of
these innocent people whatever their
religion or nationality deserve our
sympathy and our prayers what joining me
now is Sha's mother Ricarda Luke from a
village near Tel Aviv thank you so much
for joining me uh tonight I've been
thinking about you and your daughter and
the others who were taken hostage since
last weekend I can't imagine the horror
the pain the agony that you're going
through
but you believe that there may be a
glimmer of hope that your daughter may
still be alive tell me about
that yes we hope that our daughter is
still alive we we got some reports from
an information that she is held in a
hospital and she's injured badly on the
head so we still do have hope even after
this horrific video um seeing her on on
the truck
I mean the world watched this video of
your daughter everybody uh assumed that
she must be dead I can't again begin to
imagine what it must have been like for
you her mother to have seen that
video uh how has this been for you I
mean other than hellish how are you
coping at the beginning it was really
horrible I mean they send it through
social media to my eldest son and she's
he started crying and screaming and he
said that's shenny that's shenny that's
that's her and and we didn't understand
what's happening and we saw this movie L
lying on this pickup truck seems
unconscious with blood and people around
her and spitting on her and humiliating
her it's you just can't imagine it as a
parent it's it's so I don't know it it
breaks you completely at this moment you
don't know how how could this happen how
how can this happen to me it's it's the
worst nightmare uh yeah I mean it's the
worst nightmare for any parent I have
three sons and a daughter um when I saw
that video not even knowing obviously
you or your family or your daughter I it
was horrifying absolutely horrifying uh
and what has gone on since although it's
given you hope it's also horrifying in
the sense that there have been text
messages sent from Shan's boyfriend
orian I believe his name is um text
messages from his phone to various
people on his contacts with phrases like
I spit on you and godamn you others
expressing a vow to liberate Palestine
from zionists uh obviously I would
imagine the fact they're able to do this
may give some hope that they're both
still alive but the the extraordinarily
vile nature of these messages sent in
this manner it's it's another blow isn't
it it's another way to degrade you as a
family yeah it's all humilation
brutality and it's just inhuman I I
don't I can't explain this Behavior I
know anything
can justify this I mean that's just Norm
not normal you've been a appealing to
the German government uh for help in
trying to get your daughter back uh are
you having much success in dealing
directly with the German government
about
this um we're dealing I have a direct
contact person they're always available
for me and we are fitting them any
information that we get that we collect
we do our own research all the time
trying to find more clues and and feed
them back to the Israeli government and
the the German
government but you know you don't get
anything in in return like you don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
if there are discussions negotiations or
something we don't know so and uh I mean
the foreign minister of Germany came and
met us in Israel and and tomorrow we
have a me meeting with the with a
counselor with the prime minister of
Germany in
Israel which is also a a nice gesture to
to meet and and even when the foreign
minister came here she was really I mean
she made a tour through the south of
Israel and she was in shock and she
heard the stories of we were many uh
German families that were talking to her
and it it was just a shock it's it's
unimaginable I know I don't think people
really realize what's going on here and
this massacre and of young and innocent
people and babies captivated and and
grandmothers kidnapped and and it's all
around us it's families here in my town
I mean it's not stories it's not Fiction
it's real I mean I have I've been
already to two funerals and and there
are little babies here that they uh
killed their parents very
cruy and it's it's all around us it's
such a small country and it's it's
really about survival
now uh how how can how can this happen
and how will it not get worse here
and yeah I I believe that another
glimmer of hope is that you've been
contacted by your daughter's Bank to say
that her credit card has been used in
Gaza and the significance of that may be
that she would have had to have somehow
given over her pin number which would
indicate that potentially she might
still be
alive yeah I don't think I think you can
do with the phone or something you can
already move some money I don't know it
was a small amount and we we know that
they try to pick it out in the Gaza
Strip in a
shop um yeah we hope we we just uh try
to catch
every little piece of information to get
New Hope yeah but that's what we found
out so far Shen was a peace campaigner a
conscientious objected to military
service
um what kind of woman was your
daughter is your daughter she was a very
Lively Lively person she liked to dance
she likes to go to festivals with her
boyfriends he was a festival organizer
and she helped him and he traveled in
Europe a lot she was the last year all
the time
traveling and she was a tuto artist and
very happy very Lively peace with
everyone she really had many friends all
over the world
and yeah that was just her living life
and peace on a great Festival everybody
had fun there and then it just turned
into a nightmare into a horror
movie Ricardo it's it's it's beyond a
nightmare I I can't like I say even
begin to comprehend what you're going
through it's every parent Ultimate
Nightmare all I can do is is join in uh
in praying that your daughter is found
alive that she's returned back to you I
hope that happens for you so much along
with all the other hostages whose
families must be all going through what
you're going through it's it's
unconscionable what happened last
weekend uh I'm very grateful to you for
joining the program tonight but more
importantly I just hope you get some
good news
soon thank you thank
you well I'm joined Now by Israel's
ambassador to the UK Zippy hotov
Ambassador thank you for coming in it's
I mean it's heartbreaking it is just to
hear one mother I mean and there are so
many there are hundreds and hundreds of
just 199 of the people are now kept
hostage in Gaza and I'm thinking about
young children thinking about uh a girl
that has autism and she's disabled I'm
thinking about Holocaust Survivors I
think we we've never experienced
anything like that as the Israeli people
we experienced Wars we experienced
Terror attacks never in since Israel was
established we experienced anything that
was as barbaric as this human as where
were you when you heard what happened I
was in Israel I was uh staying at my
parents in-law's house and 6:00 in the
morning when the first alarm came we
woke up and I think it was 8:30 when the
second alarm came in a small City next
to Tel Aviv and I told my husband this
is serious and and from an instinct
feeling because of the sirens going up
and down I had a feeling something
really bad came up and I turn uh my
phone uh on Shabbat and and I I realized
this is a war and I want to tell to
everyone who listens and follows Israel
for many years I think we never had such
a clear event that every country should
protect its people I mean you said it in
in your great opening and and I want to
Echo that this is one of those moments
in a nation's life that a country cannot
carry on without providing the very
basic obligation that every country has
to its people we need to protect our
children we are out there in Gaza not in
order to Revenge not in order to punish
I don't agree with any of those it is
partly that though let me just say why
we're doing that we're doing that to
make sure that my children my friend's
children and every child in Israel will
be protected after we've seen what
happened to our border after we've seen
what those barbaric terrorists from
Hamas came in and they beheaded babies
heads I mean the fact that those those
small babies you know we saw in the
telegraph wrapped in uh those bandages I
mean this is something breaks the heart
of every parent and you cannot see that
and the horrific photographs and
everything documented by Kamas the fact
they put children together and burn them
alive the fact they wanted to choke
people in their homes by putting them on
fire those type of barbaric actions and
and I I'll tell you more than that uh
after identifying unfortunately 1,300
Israelis that were brutally murdered the
people were recognizing the bodies they
said 80% of the bodies being tortured
and our president just exposed a booklet
that basically show that it was part of
their you know way of action that they
wanted to torture the people it was part
of their Terror actions uh raping
innocent young women uh you know taking
hostage a holocaust Survivor I mean this
is really I saw the footage of that
woman who' survived the Holocaust being
taken away and all I was struck by was
she was completely calm she was staring
ahead and she wasn't giving
them a second of of her own feelings in
that moment I thought that was just
extraordinary given what she had
obviously gone through as a young person
but but let's join uh all the
International Community including prime
minister sunak today in Parliament that
said all those people kept in hostage
must be released now and I think this is
Israel's demand and this is one of the
aims of this war is to bring them back
home 199 and let's also not be afraid as
the BBC is seemingly afraid to do to
call this what it is an act of Terror
these are terrorists I think we were we
were very vocal about what what do you
feel about the BBC refusing to call
Terror um so I think if the BBC stands
for accuracy and if the BBC stands for
um the truth it's very simple I mean
this is what terrorism is and you cannot
find any better example of terrorism so
I I really think everyone should call it
by its name and its terrorism and and I
think one more thing we need to to say
uh at this time because Israel is now in
one of its uh I would say this is not an
existential threat but this is a war an
existence because we cannot exist if our
children cannot be safe in their homes
Israel Israel has decided and people
will absolutely understand this that
Hamas has got to be eradicated in the
way that Isis was eradicated but Isis
was eradicated in a process that also
involved a lot of innocent people
getting killed on the way clearly in
what is coming now in Gaza a lot of
innocent people on the Palestinian side
are going to die as well how many is too
many and I don't have the number I just
talk about this debate about
proportionality I'm struggling to see
what is proportionate that meets the
scale of what happened last weekend let
me make that clear I don't have the
answer here but there's a fine line that
Israel is going to tread between doing
what it can to get the hostages
out paying back Revenge retaliation
whatever you want to call it for what it
I call it defense I call it defense I
mean I whatever you call it obviously
that's part of the motivation too
uh and ultimately you want to get rid of
Hamas but Hamas are embedded with
civilians we know this so the civilian
death toll is going to be very high and
the question for the International
Community is at what point does the high
moral ground which I think Israel has at
the moment because of the scale of what
happened last weekend at what point
could you risk losing that so first of
all Israel is a moral country Works
according to the international law and
according to the international law we
are allowing all the Palestinians to go
to the South area of Gaza in order to
make sure they'll be safe including
creating shelters for them with the
International Community organizations to
make sure they will be safe the only
thing let me ask you on this just just
one sec let me let me just finish the
only thing that stands as a barrier from
those Palestinians to get into a safe
place is the fact that Hamas is
preventing from its own population to
get to a safer place because it doesn't
care about its people he's using
international support not in order to
give them as you said water and
electricity but actually in order to
fire on Israel and as we speak you know
everyone is talking about this horrific
Massacre but sometimes we forget that
fighting from Kamas carries on as we
speak today Parliament being evacuated
the center of Israel being bombarded by
by those rockets and we keep having over
6,000 Rockets just in the last week so
think about it it needs to have
electricity and all those manufacturing
what do you think supports that so it's
Hamas basically taking from its own
population and using it
against I heard I hear you I hear you
but I also heard you this morning saying
there's no humanitarian crisis here by
any definition of a humanitarian crisis
that is happening that I mean you may a
portion blame to Hamas on your side let
me explain I don't think you can deny
there's a humanitarian crisis let me
explain that I'm a woman I'm a mother I
have a sympathy to any innocent child
any innocent person in the world we
don't want to harm any innocent people
we want to Target the militants we want
to Target those terrorists we want to
Target the facilities the capabilities
this is what we want to do and the
reason I said that because at the moment
in Gaza you have supplies of water you
have supplies of food and unfortunately
wait a second some of it being some say
the water has run out in many areas and
I want to explain why 90% of the water
in Gaza are not supp is not supplied by
Israel this is like a myth uh Gaza is
Israel has just 10% of this uh 90% of it
is based on their aquifers and they're
doing that by using
um machines and the machines basically
in electricity that being abused at the
moment by Hamas in order to fire my own
Hometown this is what happen just think
how irrational it is that the
International Community knowing that
Kamas started this war is blaming Israel
for what it didn't start it I'm not
blaming Israel no no all I'm saying is I
I I understand the scale of what
happened last weekend means that there
must be an unprecedented response
exactly I think any country in the world
that suffered what Israel suffered last
weekend would launch an unprecedented
response I understand that but I also
understand in my modern history that
after 9/11 America launched a series of
unprecedented responses it invaded Iraq
which I felt at the time was an illegal
Invasion that caused Isis to grow in
huge amounts of power and then kill many
many people Afghanistan was a huge mess
and continues to be a mess and is now
back in the hands of the Taliban and so
on there's not a lot of evidence that a
big invasion of a place like Gaza will
do do anything other than potentially
make the situation worse that's my
concern so can can I give you uh my
answer life is about choosing between
between Alternatives um if you have a
perfect alternative you would have gone
for the perfect alternative but going
back even for British history I you
don't want to go back to American
history by attacking mosul and killing
so many civilians and I I personally
think uh fighting Isis is a Justified
cause because Isis didn't do any good uh
for for civil civil society and and
going back to your own history when you
fight Nazi Germany you knew that there
were many many civilians got attacked
from your attacks on German cities
dresen was a symbol but you attacked
Hamburg you attacked other cities and
altogether it was over 600,000 civilian
Germans that got killed and was it worth
it in order to defeat Nazi Germany and
the answer was yes let me ask you this
just to just to finish my point is we
don't Target civilians we definitely
give them an alternative and a place to
find a shelter and we are trying to
minimize casualty because our Target is
just to remove Hamas from our border in
order to have my children to sleep peace
and quiet in their bedroom understand
but it is also true that nearly three
times as many Palestinians have died in
the last week than were killed in the
outrage on October the 7th and then that
number is going to go much much higher
so this is exactly why I think it's
unmoral equivalence because those people
got killed in Israel children women and
men were brutally targeted and murdered
in the most barbaric no no but the
people got caught in a crossfire in Gaza
people we didn't want to kill some of
them are terrorists you need to remember
that and we are targeting those cruel
people that are based in schools based
in hospitals and according by the way to
the international law Israel is allowed
to launch a military attack every time
there is a place that is puts Israel is
in danger which it is the facilities of
Hamas are based in civilian facili you
feel you talked about being a mother a
parent do you feel on a personal level
genuine sympathy with the innocent
Palestinians who are getting caught up
in this absolutely I mean my my thoughts
are to every single individual that is
caught in a war zone now but but but you
need to understand every country has
first and foremost responsibility to its
own people so if Israel will fail to
defend my children and other people's
children like we've seen those parents
that had to you know be in a shelter
hearing other like I will never forget
this video that you hear parents that
hear one of their children get executed
I mean this is those are things those
are things are totally horrific so when
this is the reality you need to
understand there was a a misconcept of
of the understanding that Hamas can be a
tiger can live by you no this tiger it
it it went out of of the cage and it did
what it did and it's a barbaric action
how do we get to peace after this so
that's a great question I think um you
cannot have peace I mean this again
going back to your history you cannot uh
have any type of negotiation with this
type of barbarism that is based on
Jihadi ideology Hamas Charter is calling
to ination of Israel and total
Destruction so it it it has no political
Vision so we need to have uh from the
other side we need have people wants to
leave peacefully with Israel we've seen
the Arab world uh opens the gate to
Israel we've seen the Abraham Accords
we've seen Saudi wants to uh normalize
with Israel I believe the future can be
better without Terror organizations and
this is why Israel is fighting this war
by the way for the West as well this is
not just Israel's fight this is the
Western world's fight just like you had
your attacks in 77 the Manchester Arena
it's the same type of ideology that
attacking innocent people and we need to
fight it together it is inarguable
finally that before this attack the
plight of the Palestinian people in Gaza
was completely unacceptable many will
see the control that Israel has wielded
in the last week as evidence that it's
an unhealthy control over the people of
Gaza and indeed potentially of the West
Bank as well my next guest will
certainly be arguing that very strongly
that until what they see is the
oppression of the Palestinian people is
properly dealt with that there will
always be this kind of I mean you can
call last weekend what you like to me
it's a disgusting Abomination but there
will always be angry people in Palestine
wanting to break out of what they see as
oppression what do you say to that um
let's just check the facts from 2000
actually actually Gaza was the uh case
study for how the world will look
without Israeli control on Palestinian
uh area territory 2005 Israel withdraws
to the international border and people
believe that a Gaza will become
immedately Singapore and look what
happen so actually it's the other way
around from 2000 to 2005 Israel doesn't
have any settlements doesn't have any
territorial demands from the
Palestinians instead of turning Gaza to
a flourishing City they took all the
international support and there was
massive support and they took it to to
build this underneath tunnel City that
became a terror City and evil city that
we saw the results and its ugly face on
last Saturday you wouldn't deny that the
living conditions of people in the Gaza
Strip for example have been completely
unacceptable and Pierce who should we
blame for that Israel doesn't control
the Gaza strips 200 Israel is Israel
blameless I would say that Israel after
it's blameless I would say Israel no
country in the world is perfect but
after 200 five you need to blame the
effective control of Hamas uh that
abused the population that kept on using
all the international support just for
one cost to harming innocent Israelis to
fire all those rockets that been fired
on our cities for years by years and
this is where every civilized person
should stand and to say we saw the real
face of Kamas on Saturday they are there
to kill innocent Jews in their beds and
we need to support Israel in this
Justified fight because Hamas is bad
both to Israelis but also to
Palestinians Ambassador thank you very
much inde for coming in and just going
back to what happened last weekend it
was horrific and when I saw that the
instant reaction on the streets of this
Capital City London with thousands of
people out in the streets celebrating
some of them with Hamas Flags I was
revolted that that was happening in my
country and the the only correct
response to what happened then was
outrage and it's been disgusting watch
people celebrating what happened to your
people so thank you for coming in I
appreciate it well thank you thank you
very much well on say next I'll take on
the controversial Pro Palestine
influencer Muhammad hijab who'll be
listening to that and I'm sure we'll
have some questions of his
[Music]
own
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back last week I interviewed the
daily wise Ben Shapiro on the crisis in
Israel his powerful emotional analysis
made headlines around the world 5
million people have watched that
interview so far a measure of the
enormous emotion and division this
conflict has awoken well among those
viewers was Muhammad hijab the
controversial Pro Palestine influencer
with nearly a million YouTube
subscribers of his own here's what he
had to say about it do you think P
Morgan on fair grounds would try and
speak to me about an issue like this or
Ben Shapiro when they know what I'm
going to come with absolutely not don't
pretend you don't know who I am you've
been watching my videos you know what
I'm about your silence is deafening and
your cowardice is apparent well Muhammad
hijab joins me now Mohamed thank you
very much for coming in uh I hadn't
actually watched your videos I have now
I've watched a few of them I'm aware
you've got a massive following you got
nearly a million YouTube subscribers
you're an influential person and you
have a lot to say about this issue
obviously so I thank you for coming in
but I'm not too cowardly to talk to you
uh I don't have a horse in this race uh
I think I've tried to straddle a divide
of being fair-minded with all sides I've
had all voices on the show I commend you
for that actually to be honest for
bringing me on but do realize I did
caveat that with onfair ground so let's
hope that this interview is conducted I
intend to be completely Fair sure I
promise you because all I want to get to
here is a real sense of what is going to
happen we can all look back at we can
all look back let me just we can before
that sorry if if you want to say fair
grounds you introduced me as a
Palestinian controversial I actually
corrected myself right so I said Pro
Palestinian I meant to say Pro palis so
why did the word controversial come into
play I think you're controversial so are
you yeah I wouldn't so as the Ambassador
why you why didn't you introduce her in
that manner I I'm happy to say that to
many people her views would be
controversial so why didn't you
introduce me as the Oxford
graduate you want to be introduced as
that yes okay or KN for graduate go
ahead okay um no problem you can be
introduced as I think you like Frank it
makes no difference to the debate let me
ask you this where were you when you
heard about what happened on October the
7th I was at home what was your reaction
when you heard I was actually very
sickened by it and and this is something
I do want to put on the table because I
think it's fair for people to know this
in our religion we do not believe okay
as a Muslim I am a Muslim and I do not
believe in the killing of any man woman
or children um non combatants that is
not despite the religious teachings that
is because of the religious teachings so
in terms of condemning Hamas I'm just
jumping straight into it I condemn not
only Hamas but any other entity okay
wherein it's proven that this has been
done that the killing of combatants has
been done therein I condemn any party
that does it any party that kills people
or strikes at people where there it's
more probable than not that it will hit
a civilian Target I condemn them and
that's why I condemn the IDF because
when they strike they know that it's
more probably the kns going to hit
civilian targets they know that the
majority of civilians or the majority of
people that are going to be affected are
civilians we know that from the various
operations that have been conducted we
know that because now in Gaza you find
that there is a a blockade as you know
for 17 years but also there is they're
stopping them from electricity water
which is a war crime under Geneva 4 of
the of the Geneva Convention protocol 4
of the Geneva Convention so this is
something I'm surprised you didn't
actually mention to the Ambassador I did
mention I did mention it you didn't say
a war crime well I think it's an
arguable point but it's a war crime can
ask you now they are saying is at the
moment Israel is adamant they are not
breaching war crimes right it will be
determined but it will be determined
whether that's the case no no sorry
sorry mam let me just let me make a
point to you back on that I think it
surely we can agree that what happened
on October the 7th was a war crime I
mean when people are taking grandmothers
and executing them kidnapping young
children when they're when they're
killing babies in their cribs we can
agree that's War crime right okay babies
can we surely of course 100% but babies
in the crib sorry what was the evidence
for that you don't believe that happened
sorry CNN the white house uh Sky News
which you worked for all say I don't wor
SC well you your your thing I didn't
work at CNN I saw one I saw one reporter
who retracted it because she wasn't sure
about the source it's un confirmed by
the White House but then the Daily
Telegraph and the drusen post and other
sources then did publish pictures CN
indisputably show babies have been
killed no it showed one baby who he's
been charred and that video that picture
has been put up on Twitter and has been
refuted by uh many people saying that
it's actually Ai No that's completely
untrue that is that is true what's your
s your s there's been a thorough
investigation into the claim that was
put up there by some Rogue person on
Twitter that it was AI it has been
completely disproven that picture which
was published on the telegraph your is a
genuine legitimate picture what is your
source Are you seriously arguing that
babies weren't killed no I don't say
that what are you saying I'm saying give
me a source you know full well you've
been fired from The Daily Mirror for
fake images so you know full well about
the the I didn't accept they were faked
exactly the UK government did yeah they
did uhuh because the UK government just
to be clear sure sure had waged in my
view an illegal war in Iraq so you're
allowed to go against the government and
I'm not allowed to go against government
you're of course you're allowed to so
tell me now what's the SCE you seem to
be making a lot of presumptions about me
Muhammad softball question I was the
editor no there weren't I put all the
questions to the Ambassador I was the
editor of a Daily Mirror when we opposed
the Iraq war on the grounds that I
believed it was an illegal War I still
believe that to this day I think it
stained this country fantastic I don't
think you even knew that I did know that
right but I'm not that's not the point I
was making I was making the point that
if you allowed to go against the
government in their classification of a
an image then if you have Pro
Palestinian activists who are saying
actually we need to see a source
shouldn't they be entitled to that the
Daily Telegraph published on page three
should they be talking about the daily
said they had independently verified the
picture Muhammad no excuse me if you're
saying that their no excuse me primary
source in Academia I know you've done a
journalism uh degree which is frankly
it's not relevant to what we're talking
about here anyway probably is to
journalism yeah no it's not to this
conflict but we academics require
primary source evidence in order to make
it the Daily Telegraph The Daily
Telegraph said they verified the picture
that's a second resource you second you
may say that's a secondary source you
may say you don't think it's genuine I
don't agree with you but the wider point
that was my point I I want a source I
see we're arguing about here you're not
contesting that babies were killed no
I'm saying I want to see the evidence so
why why are you picking on the semantics
of the veras of one picture which has
been verified by British journalists why
are you picking on thatti journalist
some example some this wasn't as bad as
it seems British journalists are not an
academic Authority you know that full
well you've been fired from Daily Mirror
for that very purpose what I'm saying to
you is this putting this issue to deci
side I think you're trying to use as a
red herring to to move away from the B
what red hering this is a red herring
because already 1,23 children have been
killed in Gaza that's why and you didn't
ask the Ambassador that question I
literally ask the Ambassador I said
3,000 people have already been killed in
a week in Gaza but you didn't ask her
listen to my interview with the listen I
did listen but excuse me don't put words
in my mouth or say I didn't ask a
question hold let me ask a question do
you condemn the killing of those
children by the IDF I tell you what I
condemn yes or no I'm going to answer
your question honestly and truthfully
sure and I because I've tweeted about
this right okay I think that what
happened on October the 7th was one of
the worst atrocities I have ever had to
read about or watch on it happens every
day in Palestine so why do you care
about that it actually doesn't it
doesn't ites no the Israeli forces I've
got the stats for that Israeli forces do
not
go go and check mammad Israeli forces
protective Ed Israeli forces don't go
into Gaza on one day and grab
grandmothers and kill babies in their
beds rape and abuse women rape is there
any evidence for that there it's been
multiple reports in multiple mainstream
media Publications well you to sit here
deny everything no I'm not denying
anything you are no I accept that them
some civilians have been killed I do
accept this and I and I already said you
don't believe any of the reports that
women were raped no I didn't say that I
said that it's still to be do you think
they were raped no I don't know it's
like the Russell bran thing you said we
don't know see the evidence so why' you
apply two different standards when it's
Israel we know they're raped when it's
Russ brand you don't know your no it's
been reported by legitimate newsour when
it's Israel you know they're raped but
when them when it's Russell Brand you
comparison between Russell Brandon
what's happened it's the same thing it's
a rape
allegation why you why you stuttering
I'm not stuttering you are stuttering
you don't have you're contesting every
single thing that I'm saying I'm saying
at the end 1300 people yeah were
brutally people been killed on the other
side abused 2,000 people have been
killed on the I said that to the
Ambassador
okay but do you condemn that yes or no I
don't think so you refuse to condemn no
you do refuse to why you putting words
in my mouth because you're not you're
not condemning it are you what do you
want me to
condemn excellent what do I want you to
condemn I want you to condemn the fact
that the IDF knowing that it's more
probable or not pressing buttons from
the sky killing innocent civilians 1,000
of them children that that is a war
crime and that is not acceptable morally
just like you cond the other one is it
condemnable or I believe given the scale
of what Hamas did on October the 7th
Israel is entitled to no that's not what
I said goad they're entitled to defend
themselves with Force then the question
becomes Muhammad there interesting
debate sure if as it seems to me you
believe too Hamas are not a Force for
good do you believe that well I think
that anybody who kills children and
those elements of Hamas who are killing
children right so we can agree so we
agree my point is if Israel's purpose is
to rid the world of Hamas after the
atrocity of October the 7th sure how do
they do that given that Hamas embeds
itself in civilian areas in the way that
it does everyone knows that in Gaza how
do they do that in the surgically clean
way that you seem to think they should
be doing how do you not kill C can I I
don't like any civilian death I don't
endorse any civilian death condemn it
though hang on yeah no and here's why
because I support Israel's right to
defend itself can I say no one more
point then can reply sure but the
question then becomes what is
proportionate what is a proportionate
response I don't have the answer because
I don't know what a proportionate
response to 1300 murders is when 260
young people at a music festival most of
them peaceloving people are enjoying
themselves at a festival when they get
slaughtered by people par with machine
guns I don't know what the proportionate
response is let me respond so can you
tell me you've spoken for about two
minutes you didn't do that with the
Ambassador by the way I'm just showing
you you're saying fair but but you're
not being fair so let me just let me
paint a pict be fair sure I'm genuinely
interested in what you have to say
excellent you're you're from Irish
descent we know that there was an IRA
yes in Belfast and so on okay so let me
ask you a question now if there was IR
Ira in Belfast and they were occupying
Council properties and so on and then we
have a plane of RAF going to destroy
that Council of property destroy all of
Belfast flatten it as one representative
said got live the IDF said that um one
of the IDF members said that we will
flatten completely that's what we want
to do we don't care about accuracy he
said we care about damage that's what he
said you didn't question her about that
but anyway if the RAF were to then go
into Belfast and D flatten as the IDF
and these guys want to do if they want
to flatten Belfast with all the white
people I'm going to use the term white
all the white people Council of States
living in there with the excuse that
we're doing it because it's proportion
proportionate uh defense to uh the
terrorist what would you say say about
that here's what I would say to you is
that acceptable or unacceptable here's
what I would say to you yeah the IRA
committed a series of atrocities over
numerous decades they targeted in their
eyes military and political
targets they usually gave some form of
warning not always okay they they were
terrorists no no they were terrorists
sure they never ever went out one day
and committed the barbaric Slaughter of
1300 no no if they did if they did sorry
no Muhammad his wife's not irrelevant
they they never did but if they did
would you ac they have to Flat way they
were outrages committed by by the lawyer
Lawless parament to my question is if
they did would you think it's accept
they never came close to committing an
outrage on that scale if they did is it
acceptable they never went in and kidna
grandmothers or killed babies in is it
acceptable or not they believe they were
fighting for better or worse and I
believe for worse and that's why I'm
glad peace was found
they believe they were F political and
Military tar I'm trying to bring it
closer to home to you're trying to
compare apples and oranges I'm not yes
you are yes you that's doing that the
the only comparison that I would say
that we saw from October the 7th and
what Hamas did is with Isis excuse me
only comparon let me ask a question let
me ask you a question a Palestinian and
Isis were taken out by the way with no
no here's my you didn't do this with the
Ambassador which you gave the show to
him no no hang on I'm giving you plenty
of time no you're not giving you plenty
you asked about the analogy of a plane
flying over targeting but you didn't
answer my question but that did happen
Muhammad with Isis would you accept Bast
to be flattened wait minute or not yes
wait a minute it never happen so the
like for like isn't it's a hypothesis
hypothetical it's not it's not I don't
do hypotheticals don't do hypothe no no
let's deal with reality okay let's deal
with reality let me let me finish then
you can ask you don't ask a question no
here's the reality British public can
see this here's the reality right let's
just public can see this yeah they can
see it yeah go they're listening to the
debate keep going right I for what it's
worth I think it's a good debate to have
right these are questions many people on
the pro Palestinian side are having I
get it I get it right but you're trying
to compare what happened on October 7th
with the IRA no I'm not
comp wait a minute I'm comparing it to
Isis and the way that the world in the
end dealt with Isis actually was to use
air strikes and many civilians were
killed a huge difference you're not you
don't understand it because you have no
idea of the religious what's the
difference between happened October 7th
and Isis the difference between the
Palestinian resistance is the following
okay any kind of thing which has
Palestinian resistance attached to it
and Isis which is as a brand of tech
fism okay is that Isis is just one of
many brands of tech fism which you don't
know what it is which is a kind of
excommunication type um heresiological
Islamic sect okay so if there's it's
nihilistic mass murder that's all they
care about listen I know what you're
saying but I'm saying something else you
agree with me don't you I do but I of
course I do but I'm you're not
understanding what I'm saying so I'm
trying to break it I am understanding
what you're saying what I'm saying is
that anything and I'm not anti-
Palestinian by the way sure but over the
many years if you B if you bother to
check what I said about it I've always
tried to shine a light on the pl of the
pales allow me to speak please because
you're just talking over me the
difference between the two are the
following right even if we assume that
the killing of combatants in most
definitions of terrorism is something
which is bring someone to be a terrorist
okay I would say that if that is the
case then the state of Israel breaks
that threshold and meets that condition
because
Israel is why is Israel not a state
terrorist if if their highest officials
are admitting that we want to damage and
we want damage and not accuracy why
answer me this question why is the state
of Israel who are illegally occupying
illegally occupying Gaza and the West
Bank according to international law and
even the icj said that okay which is as
you know an organ of the of the UN all
right so this is international
law they're occupying they're seizing
they're bombarding they're
indiscriminately killing and they're
blocking the supply lines they're using
white phosphorus they're doing what you
call mowing the grass which is every
couple of years every few years they're
killing the Palestinian people why I
want to understand what differentiates
an Israeli in the sky pressing a button
killing the civilians from somebody in
any terrorist organization shooting the
people what differen is it Israel will
say it has a right to defend itself so
will the terrorist that's what said and
they will exactly argum no it's not
though teror I read his fat Hamas I read
his fat Hamas aren't defending
themselves Bin Laden wasn't defending
defense Bin Laden was trying to as many
of the enemy as possible let me ask you
a question how could it be that an
occupier is defending itself in the
first place the the the notion that
Israel is defending itself is as absurd
as the notion that the rapist is
defending itself from the victim because
Israel is the occupier you hav hold on
EXC let me finish just let me finish an
occupier by international law definition
means that they are already in an
offensive posture if they're in an
offensive posture if someone brings you
to P Morgan grabs you by the thing
throws you into your bathroom yeah
you're in your bathroom you're screaming
and they're eating food having a good
time one day you come out of your
bathroom you try and fight one of them
you try who's defending who from who
Muhammad who self how can you self
defend when you're occupying me this
question let speak but answer the
question let me speak question fine I'm
going to speak yeah let me answer yeah I
do I believe that Israel's made a number
of bad choices that's not answer my
question wait I'm telling you what I
think you're not answer my question
telling you what I think go ahead okay I
don't think Israel's been perfect at all
right you the moral High Ground I think
a lot of the decisions Israel has taken
are wrong I think Benjamin Netanyahu by
the way his attempts to usurp the power
of the Supreme Court Myster in Israel
has been a complete disaster did you
condemn them from killing civilians or
not I do not and I will defend them this
week wait I will defend them this week
in defending themselves against one of
the worst Terror attacks ever so you can
kill civilians for that you you can
Target Hamas can you target no hold on
if H if Hamas the controlling
Raz this is a false members of the
public die this you're talking about
fallacies this is called the m and
Bailey fallacy which is that you're
trying to defend one controversial idea
by using another it's Martin and Bailey
fallacy you can check up in your own
time the point is this I'm not asking
you whether Israel has a right to defend
itself we've already said of the impos
The Logical and legal impossibility The
Logical and legal impossibility of an
occupying power according to
international law of actually defending
itself because let me finish let me
finish it's already in an offensive
posture now I'm saying this if it is the
case you're just saying it's defending
itself against Hamas is the only way to
defend itself against Hamas by dropping
bombs in the most densely populated
areas one of the most densely populated
areas in the world is that the only way
it's a false dyot you're creating a
false they can do surgic they can do
they can do they can go in and they can
Target we're going to take a short break
I actually I'm going to keep you here I
want to finish this I want to give you
the time I think it's an important
debate an important conversation but you
have to answer my questions I will we'll
come back yeah but actually you have to
answer mine it's my show actually I just
I can answer for the record you can ask
me many questions you want but I'll tell
you what I think I've answered all your
question going take a short break we're
going to come back and we're going to
finish with a few more minutes okay
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to P says well Muhammad
hijab is still with me mamad we've had
look we've had a lively debate I knew it
would be a lively debate this is a very
uh important issue it's a very it's a
passionate issue people on both sides
you know if I tweet about anything
doesn't matter what I say
one side if I'm even remotely
sympathetic to them the other side poor
abuse and vice versa and so on let's try
and cut through it all and get to what
happens here how do we find peace in the
Middle East I've been covering Israel
Palestine since I've been in journalist
three decades and it seems to me we're
as far away now as we've ever been how
do you think we get to you surprised
look H even Hamas some four five years
ago they even agreed to the 1967 lines
the borders and what what you have to
understand that this cannot be
scapegoated on Hamas because before
hamas's existence this was still going
on this was going on before Israel's
existence do you believe in in a
two-state solution no I I believe in
look even Hamas was proposing a
two-state do you believe in it look
there's advantages and disadvantage of
this a different I don't know I mean
it's it's a difficult one I'll be honest
could you imagine two states next to
each other living in peace Palestine
Israel look it's a possibility I mean as
I say even Hamas was saying that that's
a possibility I mean this was four years
ago but I want to bring to your
attention is that nothing can happen if
the international body or the UN becomes
a toothless agency in 2018 to 19 when uh
actually 221 people were killed on a
peaceful protest in Gaza it was called
the Great March of Gaza 220 what people
died Hamas didn't shoot a bullet uh no
rocket was launched yeah so 220 people
died and this is um Nar even mentioned
by the UN and these kind of agencies
they tried to bring it up the
Palestinian authority to they Tred to
bring this up to the what you call the
icj which is part of the UN okay what
happened with the Donald Trump
Administration they th they threatened
to freeze the assets of the icj which
which tells you the following what are
the Palestinian people to do because the
fact of the matter is if they try and
bring it up let me ask you let me ask
finish the point they try let me finish
the point if they're trying and bring it
up we're running out of time that's why
I'm jumping if they're try and bring it
up to international law it's it's
thwarted I do think International
international law matters sure I just
don't believe that any any peace can be
achieved with Hamas in charge do you
before Hamas now after what happened
last weekend before forget about last
weekend last weekend has can't forget
about last weekend no it's not before
last weekend before Hamas in 1987 this
was still going on but not on this scale
and wor no it wasn't as bad as this what
are you talking about what happened on
October that shows ignorance the single
worst assault on a populist since 911 it
was Y kapo what was 20600 people died by
the way 1973 that's false in one day in
one day I don't know about 600 people
died in one M I've got to leave it there
we run out of time I gave you more time
than I planned to I hope you appreciate
that and I appreciate you coming in
that's it for me tomorrow I'll be joined
by Dylan danis whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored good
[Music]
night
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King CU I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying he's mocked
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
St working just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this war making me
cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betrayed keep it award
winning Lucy Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about Le he wants NHS manages
to be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what seven years down the
line I mean it's completely ludicrous it
was clearly something of the face of the
ward so it's even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
ward she' have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of walth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we lab
29 the
can did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls let it
roll